Năm 5 sau em sẽ bán gơ lối đất này
Wai Rồi Sài Gòn
có thể mua đúng rồi
Đây là con đường đi đường vòng
Với những người xong muốn tích
Ở Sài Gòn, hả?
Còn có thể nói thôi đi
Bây giờ một tây yet
Mua Sài Gòn có quá
Thì ăn cho nó một tây lên mình dưới mua
Đừng một lối nó rất là đẹp
Một tây lối nó một lối nó rất đẹp
Ở bên dưới
Thì với
Một tây cọng mới năm 5 triệu tiền vài nghe nghe đi quá đơn chảy nữa
Và 2 sau em tả hất kí gương nghe nghe nghe giúp ăn đi
Và em chỉu có ở thời gian 3 đến 5 năm
Năm 5 sau em sẽ bán gơ lối nó mẹ
Wai Rồi Sài Gòn có thể mua đúng một cái hộ
Đây là con đường đi đường vòng
Với những người xong muốn tích
Để sửa đúng một cái hộ
Nhệ nhiều nhiều bạn lấy hộ lắm muốn để đế lắm gì
Nó là buồn là pịch sáng
Trưng phải mạm
Bắt em ở đó và em làm nó đúng nhé
Bây giờ anh này đúng đây này
Nen lúc này là nó chảy là về con cắt
Về con cắt bị chí để lý
Nhưng mà thè là tối ké bản hế mua đi
Các bạn lấy cái nhè này các bạn cho thôi
Các bạn lấy tỉnh của bạn lấy lên để thử kênh hộ để các bạn hả?
Các bạn vẫn xử dụt lại sẻ